what's up you bad [ __ ] the
jungle joing it look my boss [ __ ]
Jews isn't what's happening you bad
[ __ ] it's happy st. Paddy's Day
for the [ __ ] Irish you know I love
you to all my heart
it's the spit Mick holiday today so lose
your [ __ ] mind you [ __ ] savages
it's a beautiful day to be alive the sun
shining the birds are chirping and God
gave you another day just think you're
taking up somebody's ass how bad it'll
bother you I'm not gonna waste your time
with any meaningless chitter chatter
this morning it's just us and a little
bit of [ __ ] reefer I gotta walk my
child to school so I figured I'd get
together with you little [ __ ] and
just let's just burn one real quick so
we said we did what how's that feel some
tremendous [ __ ] weed I got the
[ __ ] super sour diesel I got the RG
26 mixed in the [ __ ] forget about it's
gonna be a big day for every shot an
Irishman does I smoked 22 [ __ ] bong
hits you understand me that's a lot of
[ __ ] bong hits Joey leave WK & z
a little that's a couple your beads for
that I'm thinking about jiu-jitsu maybe
a little [ __ ] kettlebells kind of
spot it distorts another 1015 if you're
around you're lurking and the Hollywood
area with my man Tommy Easter where's my
manly sigh at where's my man Lawrence of
Arabia where's my man [ __ ] what a
boxer clearway you [ __ ] that
I'm saying way you [ __ ] that
you hit your bong like a savage when
love smoke I'm reef with your
[ __ ] on a beautiful Thursday
morning March 17 2016 a big weekend
I got Bakersfield and next week it's
Easter week big week full of Jews
they're jumping up and down on Good
Friday you know I'm saying if you're a
Jew and you ain't jumping up and down on
Good Friday we're kind of [ __ ] Jew oh
yeah that's all I got asked
besides that that's it dang how much I
can come out here yelling you
[ __ ]
tell you is all the suck my dick believe
that type of thing it's a big type of
[ __ ] love day I'm playing
just went to a few more [ __ ] balls
you know Mingo
never a dull moment here you guys
thinking smoking reefer trying to lose
some weight trying to get healthy
happy birthday you Catholic
I love it I tell you [ __ ] I
love smoking good reefer
there's good chicken colors there's a
lot of good things online but there's
nothing good like good flop and reefer a
good batch of [ __ ] and kill the devil
I likes better this time you
[ __ ] Colette day I'm stoned
already yes I'm being buff already a
sling they can eat chicken wings like a
[ __ ]
I love buffle on one of my [ __ ]
favorite places on earth I know some
people don't feel that way but I ain't
most [ __ ] people what I like about
Buffalo is the [ __ ] heart every time
little Buffalo on a heart that beef on
WIC I straight up protein for the
[ __ ] helmet of love you understand me
I'm born Andean Apple little jump the
great place that love I got a good
[ __ ] place I'm gonna Pittsburgh
jabish arrow up there the teacher gonna
go up there see the legends the statue
of Roberto and going on Omaha Nebraska
this year the savage dead tour takes me
to a lot of great [ __ ] places man and
I go too much mom you know but I have a
slow down Canada won't let me to [ __ ] in
what am I gonna do I got problems I
should have watched myself more when I
was a young guy but I didn't and this is
what happens this is why you gotta learn
from you [ __ ] uncle joy I'm trying to
get a casino in Miami and that's it it's
Thursday [ __ ] get out there
oh yeah we'll know seek at the anything
goes yep okay boy and being missing a
tear happy now
hope you get a little itty LOV in this
hour gonna see no oh yeah there Martin
it give my mother loved being a soul and
nobody wants to do that [ __ ] Joey why
you speaking Spanish what is [ __ ]
America they're gonna speak a little
bilingual I got two different type of
[ __ ] they even saying
I smoked one more bolt
and then I got a [ __ ] not the light what
are you gonna do
I omit how she was people suck my dick
comes up we hanging our [ __ ]
Rubio get it together I love spending
this little time with you guys
this means the world who said it my
jokes or whatever it's just us smoking a
bowl does this who does this
everybody have a show up would pop and
get on us on air or whatever looking
well Franklin family
yeah I'd say this is about family just
not smoking a [ __ ] them or equal suena
like they play out and fine in this is
just us man
no is no fakeness no celebrities no
nothing just I smoking a flop in Bowl my
family you gotta make it him that's the
most important thing at the end of the
week anybody could be a brother a
[ __ ] sister but uh [ __ ] we're [ __ ]
faculty like the [ __ ] Pointer Sisters
in 83
all right I gotta take two steps to the
rear and get out of here nobody
you [ __ ] know nobody loves you
[ __ ] ain't coming for Joe eat
[ __ ] go out there don't take [ __ ] from
nobody and [ __ ] keep your eyes open
these little militant [ __ ]
every way understand you got to keep you
guys know Chloe won't come I be the
[ __ ] here where it well I'm a wrong
bear up halfway there oh yeah my mom a
lot more room that the mundo everybody
anybody at my mom and I paint now it I
love you [ __ ] wrong my or
anything [ __ ] it won't start with you
[ __ ] nut sack grab that [ __ ]
sniff your [ __ ] fingers and go out
there get what belongs to you
[ __ ] a gang member for sure never
go home it and at the end of the day
[ __ ] it young Sam we have a good time
we'd giggle with more a few balls I love
you [ __ ] stay black I got you
today I'll be back checking in with you
about [ __ ] lifestyle let me taste
some don't show up unless your eyeballs
are red okay I don't want no [ __ ]
Christian don't show up on this guy was
a [ __ ] this red is mine I love you
[ __ ] stay black keep guys up